sean salisbury morning host sean
salsbury show which is convenient that
sean is hosting that on sportstalk 790
and houston former nfl quarterback and
friend of the show
sean good morning why fire bill o'brien
now
um it had to happen dan and i i've
probably
been knowing how tough it is to play the
position but also know how in tough it
is to watch coaches winnings tough
and i've probably been a little bit more
patient with bill
than most people in this city they've
been begging for it for years
but what set me off yesterday morning
was maybe this is the reality because
this is how he feels
is listen to the press conference after
the game when he said hey
we got a bunch of great guys and we
played hard and we didn't give up
it told me it's moral victory monday and
that just getting there is okay
it had to happen now because you got to
send a loud message not only to your
coaches
and to this city band but the players
are under achieving as well and i think
you put them on
notice this is long overdue i don't like
to see guys get fired but it's the
business that's why you get paid the big
money
and just getting there is cincinnati
bengals was
you know teams in the past getting there
is not good enough it shouldn't be good
enough and cal mcnair was late to the
party on this
and bill o'brien needed to go and they
needed they need a culture change
jack easterby needs to go too they need
to wipe it clean
and start fresh i don't know if the
mistake was becoming the gm there sean
because as a coach
i can make an argument a pretty good
argument bill o'brien was a good coach
and he was winning divisions when he
didn't have good quarterbacks
it's just it felt like once he became
the gm and then made a couple of
mistakes then everybody sort of piled on
bill o'brien and i don't know bill
o'brien i just
i think taking the gm role is probably
the reason why he's not coaching anymore
in houston your thoughts yeah
dan i 100 agree and i've been preaching
that for well since he got the gig
and anybody that dangles the gm carrot
of course the head coach is going to
take it who wouldn't
you want that power at least you want
some say in it and i can remember with
our good friend when we were doing
sportscenter stuart scott
and remember when mike holmgren took the
gm job in seattle dan when he was
coaching as well
he had both and i can remember sitting
on that set and i told stuart that day
i said when he decides to give up the gm
job and goes back to just being a coach
seattle will win again and i believe the
next year the year after they were in
the super bowl and not a pat on the back
but
you can't be a doctor and a lawyer
there's only one dude that i know can do
that he's in new england and he also had
the best quarterback on the planet for
20 years so it's not a bad gig
but i'm with you and bill liked power
and the problem is dan i talked to a
head coach
and a coordinator in this league that
said
to be in a position coach you you get
about four hours a day to yourself
to be a coordinator you get about two
hours a day to yourself to be a head
coach
you need two or four more hours now you
add monday personnel decisions and he
also was the play caller for the longest
time
you just can't do it and i have not
talked to one former coach or former
front office guy yet that thought
that anybody could do both great and in
the process of trying to do both dan
he became average because i'm with you
he knows x's and o's bill's a decent
coach
the problem is if you lose the focus and
you lose track
you want to be in the fast lane the
whole time and unfortunately their team
played like they were in the slow lane
is this an attractive job yeah
for well draft ticks make it
unattractive
and they've spent the most money on any
offense in the league and yet they're
about as
their productions one of the lowest in
the league it's attractive for a couple
reasons
that with cal mcnair the owner you and i
can go four and 12 and keep our job for
seven years
you can win divisions and keep a job so
there's an overabundance of loyalty
and kind of stay out of your way but dan
as you know trying to find that guy at
quarterback's hard to do
and when you've got to sean watson who's
still got to get better he holds the
ball too long
and he needs to improve and there's no
doubt that'll have something to do like
with what greg roman's done with lamar
jackson and what andy reid and eric the
enemy have done with patrick holmes to
even make them better
great quarterbacks bring out take a six
and make him an eight and deshawn's got
that dna
but it's an attractive job number one
because if you're not a gm right now
you'll take a gm job anywhere
but houston it's texas it's football
you've got some potential you've got a
left tackle it starts there
you got a quarterback it starts there
and if you had the edge rush you'd have
the top three positions so
you've got a quarterback in any coach or
any gm
that looks at it says well i start there
you're going to go through a couple
rough patches but
you already have the quarterback and the
left tackle sewn up yeah it's an
attractive job
especially if you've not been a gm and
you're going to be a first-time gm
you working in houston living in houston
uh
you know the astros success here is
interesting
you know i'm following it and i i always
want to hear what they have to say after
they have a win
and you know now all of a sudden you
know carlos correa is like hey
what are you going to say about us now
like they don't understand
how the rest of the country views them
like you
you're not going to erase history and
for the astros to feel like
somehow it's the media's fault if
my thought is when i saw that hey all
right you beat oakland
uh all right you got to the playoffs you
had a sub 500 record
why did you cheat in the first place if
you're so damn good why did you cheat in
the first place
so why don't they just shut up and play
take your medicine and maybe you get to
a world series
dan i am with you and and living in this
town
and it's you know what's odd is that you
know this football state
texas is a football state i'm telling
you right now even with bill o'brien
while people are fired up about it
do you realize that and i know you did
this was an astros town
it's for whatever reason and there's a
sensitivity that goes along with it i
think because they think well everybody
else does it
well everybody else doing it still that
if you're if your oldest child does
something wrong it doesn't mean
well it's cool if my other two or other
three do so yeah there's a sensitivity
and i said the other day when
correa said it after beating the you
know the twins there comes a point in
time
you get two ears in one mouth use them
accordingly because
it's very sensitive maybe it's a history
of you know
we're winning now and we did we had a
bunch of 100 lost seasons
but you're right just i i would rather
you zip it and keep going and playing
well because yesterday when they're
hitting dan
they're off the hook they've got this
dangerous lineup like the yankees in
baseball but
it grates on me and i live here because
it's like at some point time remember
you made your bed you got to sleep in it
and quite frankly even though nobody
likes covid you got off the hook a
little bit for the simple reason is
you didn't have to deal with 40 000
people roasting you
for two straight years so they're able
to do it but i would just assume
they go win a world series if they can
like this and talk about it after not on
the way there because
hey you did it you deal with it and then
you got to overcome it and they're still
not there just yet
and you've been booed by 40 000 people
before uh
dan i get booed in my own home so yes i
actually have
by the way you know you know you you're
having a tough day
when you say when people ask you over
your career well did you get booed yeah
more by the home crowd
and and the home crowd loves the backup
quarterback and you still got booed
here's what happened dad they say uh
sean stops are you going in rich gan and
sir you go in
then after your first throw they're
saying oh gosh
why did we put him in our backup
quarterback glows
yeah so it's the greatest gig in the
world as long as they don't expose you
but uh
who is the best quarterback who was the
best quarterback you defeated
well i'm undefeated against elway
just ask me and i remind john i i think
i might be the only quarterback in
history who's undefeated against steve
young brett favre and john elway and
that's the truth
oh honest to god i got elway in college
and there's one big difference between
me and those three guys is that they all
got mustard colored jackets
and i'm sitting here listening to you
dog me about my winnipeg grey cup
but i did i beat all three of those guys
so they're the best i beat but i also
lost to some guys that you'd say
nice john way to go you lost that guy
there you go you did have those names
ready
let me tell you something a little too
real you know bob costas carries around
mickey mantle's baseball card
i got it laminated my wallet
hey oh you wanted to see the highlight
sure let me get that for you
yeah no doubt about it i've mentioned
this before and you played the position
uh when rogers is playing at a high
level
i've never seen a quarterback make it
look easier and that includes
montana elway brady
even mahomes now there's some i i don't
know what it is
so when you see rogers when he does it
like at
you know he's oh my god i mean i why
does he make it how does he make it look
so easy
well for doesn't it seem like he's like
when he's got something he knows
something that the rest of us don't
yes it does and dan i i was fortunate to
play
in the golden era i just wasn't one of
them mourinho and elway and
ellie and el uh farve and and montana
and young you started in warren moon
there's listen marino was the best pure
thrower i ever saw joe namath had a
great release too
aaron rodgers as quickly as it comes out
dan it's so
the i think it's probably because you
think he's kind of casual
but there's an intensity that goes with
him and i think i there's very few
players at his position that i know
take his anger and apply it to not only
his own coach saying oh really
you drafted a coach in the first round a
player in the first round i'm going to
show you why
he's going to be sitting there for five
years i think he bottles it up
and nobody imposes his will on somebody
smoother and better and it is he's like
fonzie
he he did he's like it's our like arthur
fonzerrell's like everything's just cool
and i do it but he
he feels like he knows something the
rest of us don't
but watching him throw a football i'm
not sure in the history that i've
covered it played it or watched it
i've seen anybody throw it quicker
smoother
and with more accuracy and with more
confidence on throws no human being has
any business to attempt
off the ground on the ground off
schedule on schedule when he's going
like this there's no better player in
the world than him
and mahomes last night it wasn't a great
performance but i give a lot of credit
to
the game plan there with the patriots
and we'd love to say
now we have the blueprint here well you
have to have bill belichick that helps
with your blueprint and the secondary is
really good in new england
can you see teams because i would never
blitz my homes i mean the reason why san
francisco was going to win the super
bowl is
they weren't blitzing they didn't have
to blitz mahomes
that front four was great and you put
pressure and then keep
you know everybody back build basically
just said last night
i got eight defensive backs i'm not
gonna put any pressure on you we'll
blitz you twice
can you see teams like my strategy would
be
we got to run the ball limit the number
of times he gets on the field
and then i'm just going to make you get
the throw football into a tight window
yes and hope damn that your quarterback
matches him
that you got another guy like him on the
other side of the ball that could at
least
score because he's going to yawn his way
to three touchdowns and their game
planning is so
and it's great it's all fine and dandy
you know when you got a good scheme on
defense the problem is they got a whole
bunch of guys their fifth guy
is better than their fifth options like
man i wish i had him as my one or two
option and mahomes knows how to find him
and the kind of a great player is when
you can take one and i've always said
this when you're playing a bad game or
by his standards an average game and you
still find ways to win
and i'm with you dan the best way with a
guy like that if you're going to play
single with airspeed
he's going to find the open guy he can
take a nine step drop falling back he
can take a three-step drop he can throw
a screen
they'll bubble at the goal line with the
bubble screen with the tight end
but for me i'm with you i peyton manning
used to be great at this
defensive coordinator see they don't
believe you have enough patience to go
80 yards five times in a game
so they'll make you do it and a guy like
manning or breeze has always said well
i'll i'll match that because i'll i'll
be patient i'll throw the check down
eight ten times
i'm with you i can't blitz him because
if you don't get to him you're dead
so what you do is you make him get to
the point like all great players do
i threw three checkdowns i gotta force
this one i hope you get a tip ball
interception
i would rush three or four and i would
play coverage against him and hope that
you got three or four guys that can at
least make him move off his spot
sometimes but i'm with you zone go
through your progressions be patient
if you're going to beat me you're
beating me 17 to 10
i can't let you beat me 35 to 21 because
if they're in that 28 points or better
there's not a team in football that can
touch them always good to check in with
you sean thanks for joining
us and uh we appreciate it thank you and
by the way vanilla dipped
cone and chocolate when you take the
guys to ice cream that's for me
i'm in yeah um feel me okay maybe a cup
maybe
maybe some sprinkles on it too thanks
buddy fritzy love sprinkles thank you
sean that's sean salisbury morning host
of the sean salisbury show
it's sports talk 790 in houston the
former nfl quarterback